يتواصل القتال على جبهات عديده في حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا في بخموت معارك في
الذروه وزخم متعدد الاوجه
رئيس الشركه فاجنر الذي هاجم بضراوه مؤخرا
قيادات الجيش في موسكو واتهمهم بخذلان
قواته يكرر الشكوى من نقص الذخيره معللا
انه سيترك وراءه وحدات عسكريه شيشانيه
فيما وصفها بيفاجنر لاند نقص الذخيره لا
يزال مستمرا العدو يسحب باتجاه بخموت
يوميا ما بين 400 الى 600 عسكريين وهذا هو
عدده الخسائر اليوميه من القوات
الاوكرانيه في المدينه تقريبا العدو لا
يدخر الذخائر وقد ظهر لديه ما يكفي من
المدرعات الاجنبيه واعداد كبيره من
المسيرات انه حديث عن بخموت التي اصبحت
فاجنرلاند
القتال ضار في شوارع باخمت التي ينسبها
بريكوجين لشركته وتحديدا في الشق الغربي
المتبقي من المدينه ليس في ضخمه وحدها
تدور الحرب في جبهات عده تقول روسيا ان
الاوكرانيين عززوا تحصيناتهم وتنشر صورا
لمراقبتهم واستهدافهم بمسيره تابعه لها
وتقول هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها
صدت 50 هجوما روسيا على باخمت ومارينكا
وقالت بالمقابل انها اسقطت 9 مسيرات وشنت
10 غارات على مواقع روسيه وقالت السلطات
الاوكرانيه في زابوريا جنوبا ان روسيا
اكثر من 100 هجوم خلال الساعات الماضيه
بقذائف مدفعيه ومسيرات وصواريخ جراد تشارك
زابوريا بدورها في احد التطورات اللافته
الاخرى في يوميات الحرب مع ما يتحدث عنه
مسؤولون اوكرانيون من اخلاء تنفذه القوات
الروسيه والموالون لها لبلدات ومناطق فيها
وفي خرس اللتين تعتبران اوكرانيا اراضيا
محتله تترقب روسيا الهجوم الربيعيه
المضاده عليها
كل الاخبار الوارده من الاراضي المحتله
مؤقتا فيزا مرتبطه بطريقه او باخرى
بالهجوم المضاد وذعر القوات الروسيه
والمتعاونين معها من ذلك المحتلون يواصلون
اخلاء مستوطنات عده في زباولوجيا ومناطق
اخرى دون الاعلان عن ذلك في الحرب ايضا
سجال صاروخي اخذ منحا لافتا يعلن رئيس
جمهوريه القرم الموالي لروسيا سيرجي
اكسيونوف ان الدفاع الجوي الروسي اسقط
صاروخا بالستيا اوكرانيا فوق شبه الجزيره
دون ضحايا او اضرار وفي المقابل توظف
اوكرانيا للمره الاولى منظومه باتريوت
الدفاع الجوي وتعلن اسقاط الصاروخ روسي من
طراز كينجال فرط الصوتي في كييف الخميس في
تطور يلفت الانتباه الروسي
لتاثير الامدادات الغربيه على مسار الحرب